so i asked to meet with leo hub before i
left beijing which is
probably kind of presumptuous for a
defense attache
but i wanted to explain you know
what was coming because you know i was
being asked to go back to the white
house to help
you know work on this strategy and
i could see this all entirely in my mind
this competition coming between
you think your system is better we think
our system is better
the problem is you've been taking from
our system to make your system work
what happens when we cut that link how
does your system continue to function
and i think that's where so access to
capital drives economic growth
you can paper over a lot of things in
terms of economic efficiency with
state-owned enterprises
when you when you're taking the mac the
most of the capital access to capital
that's driving
new investment when you cut that
now they have to start to stand on their
own two feet which is
state-owned enterprises which is you
know government control
find control over oh and you know how
many money into them
right so it's it's terribly inefficient
we know it's inefficient
we've been giving them money to run it
so it's like it's like your your
neighbors
your net you've got a prius and your
neighbors got you know a gas-guzzling
humvee
but he keeps coming and taking gas out
of your tank
to keep himself going and we said hey
we're not gonna so i said hey
let me meet with you and i talked to him
i said you guys have been taking
advantage of us for
for so long but you know i think it
falls on deaf ears
they actually believe that their system
is more efficient
and in in and i think leo knows
that this is not right i think he knows
it's
in it's incorrect but of course xi
jinping is
thoroughly thoroughly convinced that no
this is
this is definitely the way that we that
we want to go forward so
so when you talk about he appears to
have true autonomy he appears to have
con
more control than any leader has in
decades
because he's more communist than any
chinese leader has ever been so he's a
leader of the chinese communist party
you could almost say he is the chinese
communist party if you said
who okay you look at all the rhetoric
who believes this stuff
most fervently that would be xi jinping
which is why he finds himself
kind of uniquely in charge in china is
because he's so
he he so much believes in that system
but the problem is
the system doesn't work it doesn't work
if it doesn't have
us putting innovation technology talent
and capital into it to drive it so
when that so they actually decided to
cut it
it wasn't it wasn't so we talk about
decoupling
now even in my best day
i could not have you know predicted
that that they would that lil hell would
take the 150-page agreement
that he and lighthizer negotiated go to
zhong nang hai
and then have the leadership of the
chinese communist party say absolutely
not
my greatest fear was they were going to
say yes right which would have
put the brakes on on all of this
what they did what they said is no
we we we've made it this system works
we've
built this belt and road thing we're
just going to separate ourselves because
we have all we need
in the meantime we'll try to you know
before they shut the door completely
we'll try to get everything that we can
but it but you can see you can see in
the in the
economies of massachusetts you can see
in the economies of california
that their service exports in other
words bringing chinese into
their universities have suffered i mean
there
is a there is whether it's by the design
of the ccp or not
there is a cultural backlash against the
united states that that hadn't existed
prior to that
and i mean it brings up the question can
they home
grow their own talent do they have the
mits
and we we know that they've got the
focus on
stem education that we should have but
can they
take it to the next level can they build
out
ai capacity can they build out a better
5g network or as you say
is the reliance on the united states a
linchpin that therefore is going to
become a stumbling block for them going
forward
well i the science the soviets had great
technology what the soviets didn't have
was a good
economic system again i think
the the cutting of this linkage between
china and the free world will expose
their economic system so
can they pred today can they produce the
type of people that they need to produce
yeah i think they can
um but my sense is as that tie becomes
cut
and their system begins to close in
upon itself that will not continue so
it's
i think that what we what i'm saying is
we've reached peak
china now it's going to begin to slowly
erode because the system doesn't work
and demographics aren't exactly helping
them either and
by the way that's another part of the
belt and road initiative because
everywhere you go when you look at these
low value added manufacturing what's
going with it
10 000 chinese citizens so so they're
dealing with their dem
graphics which is primarily heavily
weighted in males
because of the one child policy and the
tendency to
abort the females so you have this you
know
over leverage in in males and so they're
starting to move those out as part of
the belt and road initiative and
and you see this in africa and you see
it in central i don't think the african
nations necessarily appreciate
that this methodology if you will
because
in terms of organic fundamental growth
for their economies china coming in
i believe there are a lot more promises
than what is
realized because they're not coming in
and creating jobs they're not coming in
and raising up the education and the
know-how
and the technical capabilities of the
populations of the countries
they're bringing their own labor right
well in
in and this is part of the effort on the
state department to
to in in commerce department to work
with these countries to say
hey look at the contracts that the
chinese are bringing you most of them
say i think all of them say
the laborers have to speak chinese they
don't say they have to be chinese they
just have to speak chinese
and so you know that's one of your many
degrees and you you know it's not that
easy that's right all foreign
yeah and not for their people and so and
what ends up happening is just like
you're saying
you know it ends up being chinese
laborers and so they don't actually
benefit from it
but but who does benefit and this is
really goes back to the
point about access to capital the ones
that benefit are the leaders of these
countries
and so you know when you say well the
people aren't going to be taken care of
well
that's not the chinese don't care about
the people they care about getting
alignment of interests with the
leadership so if you get alignment of
interests
then you know it begins it begins to be
part of this overall system i don't care
what your politics are
you know this is the way a chinese
diplomat would look at it i don't care
what your
politics are can i can i give you some
money and we can be friends
of course that well it works if you
think about that if you think
i i lived in venezuela for a short
period of my life pre-chavez
and if you think about it that's kind of
that's kind of what happens
that's that's really what the playbook
looks like but the playbook does not end
very well
when you end up saying i'm going to
to build out an economic empire by
spreading corruption worldwide
in weak countries well
yes as long as long as the rest of it is
phrased as long as the rest of us don't
keep throwing our money
and technology and talent and innovation
into it
you're right it's gonna it's it's gonna
end badly it's gonna be end badly for
for
china it's gonna end badly for russia
for iran
it's all going to end badly it's just
how long does it take for it to end
badly
well okay so you're asking a great big
question here how do you how do you
put a seat belt on wall street
bingo
[Music]
you